a father's lesson bestowed upon an
estranged son and Irish family building
a new life in the u.s. a chance meeting
between a middle-aged man and a young
woman immigrants caught up in a world of
desperation and a father whose son
happened to be a fish nominees for
original screenplay are Denny our Khan
for the barbarian invasions
Steven Knight for dirty pretty things
Andrew Stanton Bob Peterson and David
Reynolds for finding meaning Jim
Sheridan Naomi Sheridan and Kirsten
Sheridan for in America
Sophia Coppola for a lost in translation
oh my gosh and the Oscar goes to Sofia
Coppola this is Sofia Coppola's first
Academy Award this wind makes her family
the second new generation Oscar winning
family the first was the Houston's
Walter John and Angelica
thank you I can't believe I'm standing
here thank you
they heeded the calorie for giving me
this honor thank you to my dad for
everything he taught me thank you to my
brother Roman and all my friends who
were there for me when I was stuck at 12
pages and encouraged me to keep writing
and and the filmmakers whose movies came
to breathe um the filmmakers whose
movies inspired me when I was writing
the script Antonioni and wong kar-wai
and Bob Fosse and Godard and all the
others um and every writer needs a muse
mine was Bill Murray um thanks to my mom
for always encouraging us to try to make
art and thank you to Bart and Ross for
helping make my script into a movie and
thank you to everyone in focus thank you
you